If you're going to tell the story of a
metal drummer who's losing his hearing,
how do you dramatize that and connect the
audience with the character's experience?
One of the beautiful things about film is that
as a medium that combines both sound and picture,
it's actually possible to modify
the sound the audience is hearing
so that it mimics the perspective
of someone with hearing loss.
[Inaudible muffled sound]
For director Darius Maurder and
supervising sound editor Nicholas Becker
these representations of Ruben's hearing
loss were based on extensive research
into how hearing loss sounds, that started a year
before any other crew were brought onto the film.
This video is sponsored by Nordpass.
Creatingthe soundscape of deafness is extremely nuanced.
But there are a few simple techniques that are
used to great effect in the film
THOMAS : This is Alex Knickerbocker. And chances are you've probablyheard his work at some point watching tv or in a theater.
THOMAS: I've learned a lot about film soundfrom his channel and so I reached out to see if he would help me understand the artistry thatwent into the sound of "The Sound of Metal."
The two biggest factors in how we perceive sound are
frequency and amplitude.
THOMAS: In moments representing the beginning of Ruben's hearing loss things don'tjust sound quieter but are duller and muffled
[low rumbling - muffled dialogue]
ALEX: As we start losing our hearing we're not just
losing all frequencies at the same rate.
It's notlike turning a volume knob down we're actually
losing each individual frequency differently.
RUBEN: [muffled] I can't hear anything.
THOMAS: most of what Ruben can still hear
are lower end frequencies and so
these frequencies are what we get to hear as
the audience when we're in his perspective.
RUBEN: [muffled] I can hear you.
THOMAS: Some of the work to create this effect can be done
in post-production.
ALEX: You can mimic that simply by recording your voice into a normal microphoneand rolling off all the high frequencies until
only those lower frequencies are left.
THOMAS: for example i could use an equalizer on my voice to cut out the high end and makeit sound more muffled like you're hearing now. [sound becomes muffled]
THOMAS: But creating this effect as accurately and
richly as possible starts even in how you
approach recording the sound.
ALEX: There's a type ofmicrophone called a contact mic and it picks up sound not through the air as a normal microphone
would but through vibrations in solid objects.
ALEX: So the microphone needs to be in direct contact with
whatever object it's going to record sound through.
[low metallic drumming]
ALEX: So what you end up with is a very
different perception of sound
because you're not hearing it travel through
air as normal it's coming through very condensedsolid matter.
THOMAS: For example in this scene a contact
mic placed directly on the slide would have a very
different perception of the sound of Ruben
drumming than a typical microphone would.
[low metallic drumming]
This difference in perception that
can be captured with a contact mic
was an important piece of illustrating Rubin's
experience of hearing loss for the audience.
For Nicholas Becker sometimes even the
existing recording equipment wasn't enough.
"I was able to build a small microphone that you
can put in your mouth without it being broken
we were able to really recall
all the inner sounds from Riz
racing heartbeats blood pressure
tendons moves muscle and bone movements."
[low rumbling + clicking and popping sounds]
THOMAS: But creating a compelling sound experience
for the audience and telling the film's story
wasn't just about being able to create an accurate
representation of reuben's subjective perspective.
One of the most important elements is how the
film uses the movement between sonic perspectives
and the contrast between loud
and quiet moments in the film.
This is ridiculous
ALEX: One of my favorite sonicchoices throughout the entire film is the use of contrast,
between perspectives between loud
versus quiet between delicate versus intense.
[loud drumming, electric guitar]
ALEX: With a film titled the sound
of metal you expect that to be
abrasive to some degree you expect
it to be really over the top
The opening sequence of the concert is just that
it's extremely aggressive it's really intense
sound and then the second you get away from that
it cuts to...
ALEX: A peaceful morning inside of basically a camper out in the middle of a parking lot.
Usingthat kind of contrast just in perspective changes really draws your attention to how loud
something is or how aggressive somethingis
and then gives you a point of reference that's
totally separate from what that was just like so
it guides the audience's attention very
effectively.
THOMAS: That contrast between the loud concert and the quiet environment the next day makesus more aware of the sound in the camper and
Ruben's environment, without drawing too
much attention to the sound design itself
[loud breaths - coffee brewing]
ALEX: You have all of these little
subtle details of the birds outside...
[seagulls - distant traffic]
ALEX: The atmospheres feel just a
little bit more pristine...
And even down to the foley or the production
recordings of the blender going in the
morning and all the little details of the foley
as the characters move around the trailer itself.
[cloth rustling - creaking]
ALEX:  It's all this stuff that you
wouldn't ordinarily think of.
Drawing our attention to these sounds
is important because it increases our
awareness of their absence the next day
as Ruben begins to lose his hearing.
[muffled rumbling]
The same idea can be applied when you're
switching back and forth between perspectives from
the you know normal perception of of the world
around you.
PHARMACIST: It's probably a two out of ten in terms of his hearing he can't he's having
trouble even communicating with me.
ALEX: Versuswhat it's like to perceive those same
things without being able to hear them.
[muffled rumbling - inaudible dialogue]
ALEX:  Having that contrast makes the starkness of
silence that much more intense and that muchmore heavy.
THOMAS: The film spends a lot of time inside
Ruben's auditory perspective at the beginning
often tying these moments to more subjective shots
that places inside Ruben's perspective visually.
But as the story moves along more time is
spent back in the auditory perspective of
full hearing and the film only uses Ruben's
auditory perspective for emphasis.
THOMAS: But becausethe film returns mostly to the perspective of full
hearing during Ruben's stay at the deaf community...
What?
THOMAS: There are lots of scenes
with no dialogue or music.
THOMAS: And because of that the sounds from
the environment and the movements of
the characters take more of a center
stage than they would in most films.
ALEX: The sound team did a really effective job with
this film in the quiet and subtle moments because
from a technical perspective once you start
taking away music you take away a lot of
you know over-the-top action stuff, sonically
there's not really a whole lot to hide behind.
So you better make sure that your production
sound is really clean you don't have any
traffic, you don't have anything that
isn't going on in picture to distract,
and you have to make sure that all of the
background layers of sounds, from the birds outside...
...to maybe the creaking of the old house...
...to the wind coming through you
know maybe a drafty point a window...
...all of those little details need to be
exactly right. One of the hardest balances
to find in those moments is how loud you
play certain foley movements you know even
the smallest most delicate cloth movements,
if you don't hear those to a degree
a film sounds lifeless and you don't notice
it until it's not there. So during these scenes
when you have a whole group of people not
talking they're just signing to each other...
...the foley of cloth movement...
...the foley of the actual sound of your hands.
You
know if you get really close into a microphone... [hands rustling]
You can hear that. You can hear that there
is some movement to it, but obviously if you
overplay that it's going to sound
unnatural and draw attention to itself.
So that balance that they struck in those
scenes had to have been extremely delicate.
[wind - quiet creaking screen door]
THOMAS: Ultimately the sound design plays a big role in
the emotional story arc and Ruben's character arc
in the film. The contrast we talked about earlier
of the loud distorted sounds of the metal concert,
against both the quieter sounds of
the next day, and Ruben's hearing loss,
sets up a kind of sonic motif that bookends
the story. Spoilers for the end of the movieahead.
Once Rubin gets cochlear implants the
film's interpretation of what this sounds like.
[metallic distorted city sounds]
THOMAS: While less pleasant and musical than
the concert music the film opens with...
[loud distorted metallic guitar]
[loud metallic bell striking]
...bears some striking resemblance nonetheless.
Through distortion and compression everything
sounds overwhelming, metallic, and grating. At
both the beginning and the end of the film
there's a shift from a sound of metal, to quiet.
And it's Ruben's change in how he perceives
these two shifts that marks his character's
development.
The first shift is something lost
And the second through the acceptance Ruben
has learned is something gained.
[total silence]
Huge thank youonce again to Alex for his help on this video.
He makes some of the best educational content
on YouTube about sound. And thank you to my
sponsor nordpass for sponsoring this video.
I'm very excited to tell you about nordpass
because i genuinely believe everyone should be
using a password manager on the internet we've all
had to deal with the headache that is having to
manage our passwords writing your passwords down
or storing them in your browser is inconvenient
and insecure and using the same easy to remember
passwords over and over again for multiple
websites puts you at a huge security risk but you
can solve both of these problems at the same time
increase your security and make your life easier
by using nordpass i've been using a password
manager for years and i would hate to have to go
back to not using one you can use nor pass for
free on one device but premium is super affordable
it allows you to access your password securely
on up to six devices it lets you share passwords
like a netflix password with other people securely
and it automatically checks your passwords against
security breaches to make sure they're secure you
can get 70 off as a part of the end of winter sale
which is ending very soon by going to nordpass.com
thomasflight go to nordpass.com thomasflight
or click the link in the description
to sign up for premium and get 70
off plus an extra month for free